okay but Chazz we're back we're going to
do a mission I don't know what the [ __ ]
I'm dead honey turn off you think I had
another run-in with it people we're
gonna do a thief go it carefully the
thieves guild his maven blackbriar back
I don't know you you and riften looking
for trouble yes yeah well I got last
thing the black briars need is some
stranger stick the Blackfriars have
ripped it in their pocket one of the
thieves guild watching their back so
keep me hidden I'm all i watch the
streets for him if you need dirt on
anything I'm your guy but it'll cost you
suit yourself i'll be at the docks if
you change your mind okay you just
Ranger here too huh Aaron task I'm
really getting tired of your excuses
when you borrow the money you said you'd
pay it back on time the bay and the bar
let's say let's say people have ripped
it heed my words the return of the
Dragons is not mere coincidence running
a little annoyed i could slung it
assigns the lady Laura a little like ah
here we go what you're talking it is
filled with your get a little low on car
and embrace the tea checking account and
made enough time it's all about sizing
up earmarked life the way they walk what
they're rarely wrong it should dead
giveaway sort of an understanding these
people but that's where you're wrong
laughs wealth is my business maybe you'd
like to take to perform but I need an
extra pair of time very well talent and
in my line of work myself extra hand and
it would be simple I'm going to cause a
distraction you're gonna steal me decis
once you have it I want you to place it
in brown shades pocket without him
noticing there's someone that wants to
see him put out a bit I'll be out in the
mark meet me then if you still got the
stomach for it
okay so we're doing that I'll Student
News wait success I don't have any
business with you so get out of my yeah
people are [ __ ] or written scary yeah
what do you walk this is about the meter
e we can talk later okay looked good
wait until I start a distraction then
show me what you're made of you in town
a here for the fishing i get i have
something amazing to show you that
commands your attention you need to hear
them no pushing no shoving plenty bro
okay [ __ ] yeah bountiful although I
there we go like Drago there's a golden
glow estate why didn't you neck when I
got close the mercenaries are you
talking about radiology what is it this
time I don't think you want those stairs
anymore this is there any Chris as a
willing one on get left out that's what
you said about the Wiz better and it
turned out to be crushed in your group
mixed with water okay plant
well I see that my time is up come back
tomorrow if you wish goodbye yes we did
it looks like I chose the right person
by Jenna fecha and here you go your
payment just as I promised the way
things have been going around here it's
a relief that our plan went off without
a hitch very well yeah my organisation
but never mind that you did the job and
you did it well alright then let's put
that to the test the group i represent
house its home in the rat way beneath
rishta a tavern called the ragged flagon
get there in one piece and we'll stop
okay thanks guys